well there's no doubt you you know just
before I went to Latin America it was 60
80 60 90 I mean the whole social
environment in Europe was a one of
socialism communism communist parties in
Italy and France were extremely strong
and there was a real real possibility
that the Western Europe would become
communistic through a democratic way now
when i arrived in and Chile it was just
before the election presidential
election where I ended finally won he
won with this very very small vote he
had 37 percent of the votes and those
are the seven percent of the votes were
being split up in seven different
parties so there was really not one
party behind it was low near a popular
that was half winning this election but
this of course had a major impact in the
political environment first of all
Europe was very much in favor of this
first step to communism through a
democratic process and therefore all of
the European media were extremely
favorable to this change over there and
I would say they were so favorable that
perhaps they did not paint the right
picture when the reported about what was
really going on in in Chile which turned
out to become a major economic mess with
within a very short period there was
nothing to eat people had to queue up
for the eight hours in order to get a
fleet of oil supermarkets were
completely empty and nationalization was
going on in a very very strong manner
just because factories were not able to
run anymore because they were running
out of Roma tools being at the one hand
national sales manager as I started down
there and being responsible the
interaction with the trade when there is
such a shortage puts quite an impressive
burden
yourself because you had to assure that
the few products that we had would be
distributed in an equal manner because
if you would favor somebody you might
very easily become a reason for
nationalisation i moved to rapidly
forward from there to become the
marketing manager and that helped me
then to be a member of the management
board and with that again i had to start
the negotiate with government about
prices raw material we had to negotiate
with the labor unions inside which were
politically of course organized dancing
like this so in this three years I got
what I would say a basic basic social
political and economic training on all
aspects which later on unfortunately or
fortunately helped me quite a lot in
many other situations and I still think
helped me today as state intervention is
becoming again an aspect that is more
growing than becoming less take
Venezuela and we have become
nationalized him and as well a big part
of our business in the 70s 1976 1977 I
had then the the task to negotiate this
nationalization in the 80s finally
achieved it in 86 so almost ten years
that Nestle was I was negotiating his
negotiator is nationalization and again
this experience the first experience
back in and from Chile help moles in
this situation and perhaps it was a
reason that when mr. chavez said some
time ago that he would nationalize
Nestle well I responded with a small
smile saying well of course this is his
privilege that's a privilege of
politician to decide whether he wants to
nationalize her don't nationalize the
monly important thing in such a case is
that he recognizes the value of your
investment you have done it i'm sure and
i said very clearly i'm sure he would
recognize it
good in them is pay an indemnity asian
that corresponds to investment that we
have made and I think that's very
important I think as a company we have
to recognize that the politicians have
the right to nationalize but this right
in order to be respected has to be
linked to the adequate unionization that
the investors receive who has made the
initial investment in this country a lot
of learning from that I'm learning that
we also brought in from the time we were
nationalized in Cuba for example were
again we were happy enough to negotiate
at that time with the coogan government
and we received the payment
randomization it took a long time
because there was not payment in money
was payment in sugar but we received an
adequate anization for the nationalized
business and today we have three
factories running in Cuba and we are
back again so that's life and this is
how politics and change sometimes and
once you are invited sometimes they
prefer to see outside
let me let me just to mention that for
example when we reinvest it in Venezuela
before we did that especially in the
milk sector which was a one where we
have been nationalized I went and
visited the ex-presidents who were the
responsibles at that time for the first
nationalization that we had and I asked
personally each one whether they would
agree that we would reinvest in this
sector and whether they had changed her
mind and i received the very positive
answer from all of them involved three
presidents the acting president but the
two former presidents that they would
see an engagement of mostly as a
positive thing for the country and for
the local community that's why we did it
yes I think of course we be asking
ourselves we are listening very careful
what politicians have to say we read
very careful the political program of a
presidential candidate in order to these
two to decipher what their actual will
be and of course it plays a major role
whether you make a new investment you
you don't you also look at the
legislation take for example a top-8 the
Opia some years ago didn't have a
specific legislation for a foreign
direct investment today there is one and
I think it's article number 47 who were
clearly states that in case of
nationalization that European government
commits itself to indemnity to to pay
the immunization in case they want to
nationalize now such a piece of
legislative framework of course is more
helpful if you have to make direct
amends
you